the op is one of valeran's most
controversial weapons but one thing that
isn't up for debate is that the best
players in the world can turn this
dangerous gun into a highlight machine
so today we are taking a look at the
best up plays in valoran but before we
get into the list i want to tell you
that we just put out the last episode of
season one of our newest show every
second counts brought to you by cisco
it's about the tragic missed shot that
almost changed cs go history check it
out by clicking the link in the
description below and once you've done
that strap in because here are the top
10 office plays
kicking off our list is cned who smoked
himself off and didn't even care shadow
needs to be careful here they're just
going to peek out and angel tries to
trade off of it oh my god that's an
insane show from cedar in tactical fps's
smokes are usually used to cut down
sight lines for a would-be opera but
back at vct challengers 3 europe ascends
cned used a jet smoke to defend himself
from fpx's push see ned i i feel like
they could come from any angle and he's
gonna get this first kill shadow needs
to be careful here they're just gonna
peek out and angel tries to trade off a
bit oh my god that's an insane shot from
cedar how does he do that you can't be
doing that it's absolutely magic he
performs
after getting the opening kill cened no
scoped angel threw the smoke for a truly
unbelievable kill
coming in at number nine is this classic
tens ace from the c9 days they have
fluffed up a couple of occasions there's
another kill from tens the things are
looking decent for this round at least
okay we're getting shot a few players
now
yeah
style points
that's been based off these mistakes but
here we go it's the ace for tens allowed
to roam free with open sight lines tend
to put down enemy after enemy even while
banging the omen look we know the ace
ended with a shorty kill but that was
four clean op shots in a row you gotta
let him have it
taking the number eight spot on our list
is this insane play from penny just yet
12 seconds
penny that is full penny earned the
penny s moniker once again when at vct
masters reykjavik he decided to push
through a viper wall and absolutely got
away with one no scoping someone threw a
smoke with an op is one thing
walking through it and head shotting
someone point blank
that is something else i don't know
actually it just like stopped at pillars
if there was a cipher trip that didn't
exist
holy [ __ ]
what a chad
are you kidding me
coming in at number seven is a rare omen
op rampage from yampi it's really going
to make things a little bit awkward and
it delays the push but realistically
they are still making their way around
this corner jumpy needs to be very
careful on this peak but with no trade
potential it's almost too easy for him
from loki and center inside of b main
the smoke went down it seemed like they
didn't really know what was happening
gambi still going forward with this
operator picking up every single player
he sees this is ridiculous the frenzy
reloaded
away with a fourth one player remaining
and yappy's going for these connecting
it seven to zero for team liquid
now it's rare to see any agent other
than jet pop off with the op but this
play is proof other agents can
definitely deliver on the sniper rifle
there was a frenzy kill in there but
four op kills including some pretty
up-close work also helped secure the ace
devastating
at number six it's sk rossi turning the
tides with a huge op ace he has found
five kills in the first half he had four
there's another one
he's beat able to show up
he's uh i got another kill picked up mw1
oh sk rossy three kills four this is
huge from sk rossi and he's looking for
every single victim sk ross he's got the
ac he's got every single player this man
cannot be denied
this indian superstar has shown all
sorts of incredible plays with the op
but doing it under the incredible
pressure to qualify for the apac lcq
just it's different but don't take our
word for it just watch the pop off and
who other than sk rossi to close it out
the champions of the vcc are global
esports they take down vlt
at the halfway point on our list is
another play from cena that can show you
just how much abilities make valrant's
op plays stand apart more anchoring
towards a
that's just because cena is
getting so much success with this
operator
the recon dot coming in nicely vixen is
the last to go and really if you needed
a hero for a prime game in flawless it
had to be cena
at valerian champions op maestro cned
danced circles around keith's stars with
jet's insane mobility picking up a 3k to
leave them dead in their tracks you
might also remember the series as the
one where vk exploited a cipher camera
bug and they ended up losing the
replayed match where ascends started up
7-0 ascend went on to win the inaugural
valerian champions tournament and cena's
incredible play was a big part of that
taking the number four spot is shazam
making igling and opping at the same
time look easy let's see yeah the first
contact yeah that one's easy whippy with
a slow walk right in front of him 17
seconds left they have to boot on the
jets the eye's gonna be able to go down
shazam
but he can still go for more take some
penny these players are isolated eight
seconds left there's more players for
from sentinels to deal with and the
round is over these last two players are
an elbow
and celsius still gets the kill back
shazam gets it
and zelphus goes down after time back in
the playoffs of challenger's na shazam
took a version one apart with the op i
cannot believe shazam locks it down that
well five shots and four kills
immaculate coming out from shazam to
just holding that position i said he
needed to hit his shots he did more than
just hit his shots he stopped the entire
stampede maybe they should start calling
elbow shazam's place instead
one last time at number three it's who
else but cned reminding us that no
matter the range he is one of the best
operas in the game and now it's all time
to fall to pieces the site is theirs the
ultimate comes out they've all been
noted and seen ed is keeping them back
one by one they challenge him and one by
one
looks like they're gonna fall yeah look
at this guy so sharp quick as lightning
you can see another he knows the bonkers
there and he wants it i'll feed him
another give him one more feed the beast
dragon here it is let's see if they go
for it
oh cena come on
what no what the hell was that
up against guild at challengers 1 eu
cena gave us a master class in
versatility first a long distance has
shot on draken and then a quick pick on
banca while under fire when cnet has the
op you're not safe at any range
our second place play comes from tens
giving us the ultimate thrifty play a
four bullet ace
it'd be would it be my friend but now
immortals after that last one are you
choking me his tail is really in this
pool they know they're collateral
you're sure man i mean at this point
he's definitely immortals immortals
what what can they even do they make
their way on site
no
and everything
with an ace
you've seen it a million times and
you're gonna see it again at the knights
invitational tens absolutely annihilated
c9 acing them with four bullets thanks
to two insane collats it's a place so
good even tense thinks it might be a bit
too much i used to i was so confident
with the op when uh
prior to like the nerf
and like uh the fire rate was faster
like i actually felt so confident just
going for aggressive peak after
aggressive peak i just like peaking
constantly
um i'm kind of glad that they nerfed the
gun because it was a little bit op i
would say but
um yeah i remember this clip it was it
was pretty nice
and finally the best opt play valrant
has seen so far is this nutty retake
from yemi looking to come in from behind
they'll know where both players are and
are just trying to hold within the site
b is definitely not the place you want
to be when it comes to these after plant
scenarios it can be topped off
from yummy
[ __ ] both the fin is just going flashy
at this stage and
what is that a ridiculous retake he
didn't even need his teammate in the end
back to back no scopes retaking against
two opponents who have position inside
the site
that is filthy
there we have it the top 10 op plays in
valorem so far if you think you missed
any let us know down the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
holding that tight angle you can't
really wake your weight wake your way in
there no and you can see how they set up
for this too cipher trap on cat cipher
trap on mid so six
that all fell apart so fast